44 it is Tuesday morning and all this
week here at Good Day Las Vegas we're
sharing our favorite holiday recipes
with you they've been tasty so far
yesterday you saw Nate he shared his
buttermilk Dill cashews today Candace is
taking over a side dish and showing us a
sweeter addition to your Thanksgiving
meal she's over at our 8 news now Studio
kitchen with Heather to show us what's
cooking in the oven ladies what you got
over there I'm here to eat let's be fair
I'm pretty sure that's what you're here
for Heather and you know I got you
covered this is something that my aunt
lady makes almost every year really it's
called yamalove yamalo so you know you
guys know candy yams right yeah so on
top of candy yams are marshmallows this
camera up here guys be over over the top
you put it in the oven so it gets a
little crispy on top I'm gonna give you
the uh
there we go there we go all right cool
okay now you can see right
okay so it's the marshmallow it's really
something that makes it a little bit
sweeter for the kiddos now I talked to
my dad about the actual yeah and your
dad is a chef he knows what he's talking
about so I talked to him about the yams
he kind of walked me through it and so
basically you're gonna caramelize your
yams okay use a couple pounds of yams
chop them up in little quarters and of
course I sauteed it up okay so you're
sauteing okay all right then you go
ahead and add that sugar in there the
sugar is the key you guys no we'll do
regular sugar regular sugar regular
sugar and then you'll add your cinnamon
to it just like a dash okay not too much
and of course you want to caramelize it
you want that sugar to turn in sort of
like a syrup so it's very syrupy gets a
little crusty I like a little crust oh
yeah yeah it's Gotta Have a little right
I like a little crutch to my Canyon so
then you put the marshmallows on top you
put in your bacon and it's nice and
crispy okay so here's the deal Candace
we always see you on camera eating so so
I am I'm digging it hopefully these are
clean okay I'm guessing they are
good because they're right clean most of
our
social eater here on our show I'm just
gonna I'm gonna oh it does have that
nice crunch that's the important part to
it you guys you guys want to make sure
you have the crunch to it it is really
sweet isn't it so what you want to make
sure you do you want to pair this with
like a great macaroni and cheese of
course oh yeah so greens or maybe your
turkey and of course I got you covered
what the directions and of course the
ingredients on our website newsnow.com
I'm coming to your house for
Thanksgiving actually I'm just gonna eat
this whole thing oh my gosh Sherry I'll
save you a little bite hey a little bit
no double dipping no double dipping I
saw that fork go in it
another one I'll get another one we got
a couple for you in the back here we got
you covered I promise thank you tasty I
got a Cooper now a little twist on uh on
the amps for Thanksgiving
loaf all righty all right thanks Candace